benjamin bauer bin 66 jahre alt aber den
ruf eines ofensetzer land war 20 jahre
im beruf und fit bin ich als das haben
wir nach 66 jahren kriegen wir 321 euro
wir mussten schwer arbeiten von tritten
vierte hinterhof fünften kreuz bei
schiffen abbrechen kachelmanns leben
einrühren da muss ich die öffnung setzen
als wein getrunken habe mein kreuz ist
kaputt meine knie auch die das
bayerische kaymer
ich habe 2013 ein schweren autounfall
gehabt habe ich hier noch schrauben am
rechten bein und zwei platten und danach
bei den erwachsenen fisch und was soll
ich sagen und er wurde dabei immer
schlimmer der musik der nicht mehr
vermittelt
wir kochen hierfür 120 essen im schnitt
täglich und in der woche gehen noch an
die 500 liter ein schöpfer an die
verschiedene soziale auszustellen hier
kommen hauptsächlich menschen aus sozial
benachteiligten schichten leute die
wenig geld zur verfügung haben im monat
um ihren lebensunterhalt zu bestreiten
2009 10 waren in deutschland 3,2
millionen senioren ab 66 jahren von
altersarmut betroffen
als arm gilt wer weniger als 60 prozent
des durchschnittseinkommens hat das sind
monatlich 781 euro
warum zu geringe löhne früher zu lange
aber zu große zeiten der
arbeitslosigkeit insbesondere nach dem
umbruch in den neunzigerjahren
gebrochene wir erwerbsbiografien und das
führt letztendlich auch der altersarmut
ist das absoluter armut zeugnis das in
einem land wie deutschland überhaupt
diese fast schon industrialisierte tafel
existiert und dass man den armen
menschen über solche institutionen
praktisch den lebensunterhalt gewährt
mit
[Musik]
einmal wöchentlich gehen ruhe sauer und
seine frau elaine einkaufen
[Musik]
die können wir uns wieder
oder doch meinen aktiv und wenn wir mal
so ihm ein zelt
morgen
er hat zum einstecken
eine paprika wurstfabrik salami kostet
99 cent sind firma gramm und schmeckt
sehr lecker und schon den geldbeutel
weil hier wenig haben können wir uns die
leisten und es ist mehr drin als in
anderen filialen dann nimmst du die
kekse guck mal
dann hat so könig
man hat sich daran gewöhnt mit wenig
auszukommen
ich bin mir nur nicht unterschätzt
werden
[Musik]
150 menschen kommen jeden donnerstag zu
dieser ausgabe der berliner tafel
wir haben hier seit über 15 jahren eine
lebensmittelausgabe für ja viele leute
die zusätzlich lebensmittel brauchen
weil sie staatliche leistungen fließen
die eben auch nicht so richtig reichen
finde es ganz gut dass es das gibt weil
es natürlich ich denke in jeder
gesellschaft aber leute gibt die
irgendwo durchs raster fallen also ich
denke hunger muss man nicht wenn man
sich nicht schämt ebenso war es ein
angebot anzunehmen
aber altersarmut gibt es schon weil
manche leute eben doch sehr sehr geringe
renten haben wo man eben auch nicht
wirklich gut von leben lassen
jetzt sind bedürftig aber dort steht man
nicht auf ihre armut endet nicht nein
ich schäme mich nicht mehr kompatibel
ist größer als die arbeit